hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 24 hört zu und spricht nach
basel liegt im norden der schweiz basel
liegt im norden der schweiz basel liegt
an der grenze zu deutschland und
frankreich das liegt an der grenze zu
deutschland und frankreich
schon einmal in basel warst du schon
einmal in basel
ja ich war schon auf den basel
ja ich war schon auf den basel in basel
steht das höchste gebäude der schweiz in
basel steht das höchste gebäude der
schweiz luzern liegt im zentrum der
schweiz luzern liegt die im zentrum der
schweiz luzern legt am
vierwaldstättersee luzern liegt am
vierwaldstättersee warst du schon einmal
in luzern
warst du schon einmal in luzern
nein ich war noch nie in luzern
nein ich war noch nie in luzern in
luzern gibt es die kapellbrücke in
luzern gibt es die kapellbrücke bern ist
die hauptstadt der schweiz bern ist die
hauptstadt der schweiz bern liegt an der
aare bern liegt an der aare in bern ist
das bundeshaus in bern ist
das bundeshaus die berner sprechen
berndeutsch die berner sprechen
berndeutsch genf liegt im südwesten der
schweiz genf liegt im südwesten der
schweiz genf liegt am genfersee genf
liegt am genfer see
genf ist die zweitgrößte stadt der
schweiz genf ist die zweitgrößte stadt
der schweiz in genf spricht man
französisch in genf spricht man
französisch lugano liegt im süden der
schweiz
lugano liegt im süden der schweiz in
lugano sprechen die leute italienisch in
lugano
die leute italienisch im kampf
sie ist es oft wärmer als in zürich im
kanton tessin ist es oft wärmer als in
zürich davos liegt im osten der schweiz
davos liegt im osten der schweiz davos
liegt in den bergen davos liegt in den
bergen
dort kann man skifahren oder wandern
die schweiz hat 26 kantone die schweiz
hat 26 kantone die schweiz ist
reiches land die schweiz ist ein reiches
land
die schweiz ist eine direkte demokratie
die schweiz ist ungefähr 40.000
quadratkilometer groß die schweiz ist
ungefähr 40.000 quadratkilometer groß in
der schweiz gibt es viele berge
in der schweiz gibt es viele berge in
der schweiz leben mehr als acht
millionen menschen in der schweiz leben
mehr als acht millionen menschen in der
schweiz gibt es vier landessprachen in
der schweiz gibt es vier landessprachen
zürich
ist die größte stadt der schweiz zürich
ist die größte stadt der schweiz
der gothaer
tunnel ist einer der längsten tunnel der
welt
der gott
tunnel ist einer der längsten tunnel der
welt
der rhein ist der längste fluss der
schweiz
schweiz das motto
ist der berühmteste berg der schweiz das
matterhorn ist der berühmteste berg der
schweiz im frühling blühen die blumen im
früh
link blühen die blumen im frühling ist
es warm im frühling ist es warm
im frühling werden die tage wieder
länger
im sommer ist es heiss im sommer ist es
heiss im sommer kann man in den seen und
flüssen baden im sommer kann man in den
seen und flüssen baden im sommer
die sonne im sommer scheint die sonne im
herbst regnet es oft im herbst regnet es
oft im herbst findet es oft im herbst
windet es oft im herbst fallen die
blätter von den bäumen im herbst fallen
die blätter von den bäumen im winter ist
es kalt im winter ist es kalt im winter
schneit es im winter schneit es im
winter kann man skifahren oder
schlitteln im winter
kann man skifahren oder schlitteln